how's it going bros my name is Pippa
Malcolm to yandere simulator also known
as [ __ ] is wrong with Japan simulator
okay so here we go school starts how's
it going everyone now in this episode
I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try to kidnap
senpai hi there friend how are you oh
god its empire oh my god red flag right
there how their friend how are you how
could you just [ __ ] talk to me [ __ ]
just wanted to say you have a face
you're welcome
compliment you have great [ __ ] tits
I'm not even joking you're welcome
got a compliment everyone got to have a
good reputation so step I won't suspect
that we're a psychopath uh compliment
epic portents you have a great face it
looks just like mine you're welcome
mako-chan make a check see a guy they
see yeah ziggety look at my rat it's
over twelve maybe you should let that
guy through she's like back off [ __ ]
this one it's mine this is my senpai
okay we've done a good job at
complimenting everyone now we need to go
to class oh it's a dance ring yeah it's
the Dave's party girl
I sense a city girl
and let's spend our points in biology
confirm school is over
oh my god damn it he's acting strange me
because I love you [ __ ] since T [ __ ]
secret how do I get big boobs like you
sensei oh my god not this [ __ ] again
there's the boo button now attempt I
will notice me whoa oh my god rampage
mode oh my god that's awesome hey
everyone
I mean catch ah ha ha that's awesome
your hair looks like I Selman you're
welcome I got a blend in with the ladies
so uh I had my period last night
hey we racked up in biology that means
we can use the tranquilizer that might
come in handy since it their nests
syringe
neither gotta get that get the
tranquilizer no problem no problem Anna
I think sensei I'm gonna go with the
bear panties this time and I don't give
a [ __ ] what you judge me
all right senpai I'm doing this for your
senpai why is there less people going to
school all the time if someone else
after sampai
what is this [ __ ] I bet it's you you
[ __ ] weird hairy car [ __ ] gotta go
get this arrangement [ __ ] first this
[ __ ] is gonna [ __ ] burn excuse me
lady I'm just gonna it's gonna get done
again what what's that I'm getting too
excited I feel them grow every [ __ ] all
right
[ __ ] weird eyes did they follow me
I'll show you something cool all right
all right all right [ __ ] follow me
girl now all right where will go in here
you [ __ ] follow me
follow oh how interesting how it's just
you and me now here you know what I've
seen how you look at senpai [ __ ] don't
pretend that you don't know
[Music]
don't worry breasts she's not dead she's
sleeping all right they're coming with
me
inside this box [ __ ] you narrow Chen
returns to the inn to make a sigh
carries her unconscious victim she
pushes the case back to her house perp
it's pretending to be a young musician
returning home from a show in there HM
drags the case down to her basement and
ties up her victim yes we did i ah it's
gonna be good I'm gonna wear my black
panties for this [ __ ] yeah tell me tell
me everything a bed same day same place
mine now no one will ever touch him you
will never see him again
also you have ugly hair let's talk to
him we have good reputation now so we
can make people do stuff follow me and
I'll show you something cool he's like
wow this girl is gonna show me her
titties I better follow her come in
alright it's gonna be okay yeah yeah
yeah you got it you got it but the door
it needs to be closed cuz otherwise
people will see me that guy's working so
hard not to look at my giant ass titties
the amount of will strength this man has
is quite impressive it's kind of
commendable really I feel like I almost
shouldn't kill you
but I have to for sampai don't go to
class girl who bill obstacle lobster
this [ __ ] that's right let's take some
panty shots so we can sell them of eBay
there we go
that's a good shot babble about Papa ski
buddy skip ap senpai will only love me
senpai will only love me hate can be
murder sensei since he sang joke I'm
sorry I'm sorry no no my fallen brothers
I will say this last goodbye
no we had a kill sensei for expelling me
from school take this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what
do thank you Oh a mist oh my god she
wrecked me damn since he's a badass
all right price I gotta have to end that
there that was a great time to leave a
like I really appreciate it if you
enjoyed the episode it seems fair enough
runs leave a comment about somebody's
ass and how you like it and I'll see you
in the next one
as always this is this is the toothbrush
that I stole from senpai so brushing my
teeth with this is a wonderful feeling
this is a bandage that set by threw away
some of his delicious blood is still on
it